sie versüßt dir die weihnachtszeit
du siehst du wieder zugeschneit dich mit
decken vom alltag befreit
sie versüßten die weihnachtszeit mit
reifen gefahren sagte freund
endlich wird
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt auch
heute gibt es wieder ein leckeres
plätzchen rezepte und zwar gibt es heute
sogar ein glutenfreies rezept denn ich
mache mandl marzipan hörnchen und in
diesem tag ist hat gar kein mehl
enthalten deswegen ganz gut für
diejenigen die kein gluten vertragen
ich zeige euch mal kurz die zutaten für
den teig ich habe hier 200 gramm an omas
hat dann nämlich wieder die lübecker
marzipanrohmasse 100 gramm mandeln die
sind bereits gehäutet und ein kleiner
dann in strohn saft einen halben
teelöffel zimt 100 gramm puderzucker
später brauche ich dann noch das eiweiß
also vom eigelb 1 esslöffel wasser 50
gramm mandelblättchen und später noch
100 gramm zeit mit der kurator
ich gebe jetzt alle zutaten für den teig
einfach in der küchenmaschine also man
kann die mandeln das eigelb den
puderzucker
toll ich sind recht gleich noch das sims
und zitronensaft und dann wird es
einfach kurz zu einem teig verrührt
der tiger sitzt fertig und ich hab mir
ist noch überlegt etwas zitronenschale
mit ryan zu geben orange würde auch ganz
gut passen
ich habe der bio zitrone und treibt die
noch mit rein so als zusätzliches aroma
wenn man schon keine vanille extrakt
haben neben fall noch diesen zitrone
den fertigen teig portioniert ich jetzt
direkt und zwar erstmal halten
und jetzt freue mich aus jeder oder
possierlich aus jeder hälfte zehn kleine
portionen sehen bis zwölf habe ich
ungefähr 24 mantel tönchen maz berichtet
am 24
so erst mal eine lange rolle
dann halte ich die was hab ich sag 12
genau dann noch mal die hälfte jeweils
und die dann eben durch 3
daraus formte jetzt eine kugel dann
etwas lerne ich wie so ein kleines
hörnchen mama das gleich also die enden
etwas dünner die mitte bisher dicker
die herren sind geformt und jetzt werde
ich noch bestreichen mit eiweiß und
wasser gibt es jetzt jemand rein mit dem
wasser und verrührt es kurz
und jetzt nämlich immer so ein hörnchen
und bestreicht mit dieser eiweiße und
dann kommt es direkt in die mandeln die
könnte vorher gerne mit den händen so
ein bisschen zu drücken
dann werden die dort drin gewesen
der nur noch ein bisschen an drücken
dann kommen die aufs backblech und jetzt
müssen das eben noch zu hören in formen
die männchen werden jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa zwölf minuten
gebacken und nach dem backen ist es sehr
einfach komplett abkühlen
die mantel hin sind jetzt abgekühlt und
ich habe jetzt hier bereits 100 gramm
kuvertüre dekorateure temperiert und ihr
könnt in meinem spritzgebäck video
übrigens sehen wie marco roth ihre
temperiert das habe ich jetzt hier schon
vorbereitet und jetzt nehme ich die
hörnchen und trug sie mit beiden enden
da rein
die mantel marzipan hörnchen sind jetzt
fertig und ich kann sie anrichten
und zwar habe ich dafür jetzt ein
schönes etc
ich bin die plätzchen die sehen richtig
hübsch aus und gerade wenn man jetzt
ganz viele plätzchen auf einem teller
hart zum beispiel am ersten advent oder
am zweiten oder dritten oder vierten
oder keine ahnung wann dann hat man halt
so richtig hübschen plätzchen teller und
das inhalt so plättchen die eigentlich
zu den teller suppe aufwerten finde ich
weil durch diese gehobelte mandeln und
durch die schokolade finde ich hat es so
treffend die sehen einfach super aus und
profitieren schmecken gut also die
plätzchen schmecken richtig toll nach
zitrone durch die zitronenschale sie
schmecken richtig marzipan und im moment
sind sie noch ein bisschen fest
ich denke wenn man jetzt aber in
keksdosen lagert dass er da einfach nur
ein bisschen weicher werden weil es da
einfach richtig durchziehen können auf
jeden fall sind sie wirklich richtig
aromatisch ich finde es echt super
leckere stopper probieren dann bleibt
mehr für mich auf jeden fall können hier
das rezept gerne nachlesen ob sie es mir
nicht blog.de ich finds halt toll dass
die glutenfrei sind
das heißt man einfach auch ein plätzchen
ohne weißmehl und überhaupt allgemein
ohne mehr
und ja sie sind schnell gemacht so
vereinfacht super lecker
deswegen sei empfehlenswert also ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken um die samira dreht noch ein
bisschen zeit mal den special effekt der
papa freut sich also bis zum nächsten
mal tschüss und jetzt kann ich in ruhe
essen fans nicht nur reden mussten
ja